my best advice to a couple that lives
together get security cameras put them
in your house put them in every room
that way there's no arguing you're not
going to spend hours of your
day you're a
child I told you man these BR sound like
the opposite end of the red pill they
sound crazy that's the advice that you
give to people her name is Casia West H
you know i' actually seen her before one
time she did this video you know the guy
goes hey where do you guys live how much
you pay for rent how much do you guys
pay for rent in New York and he goes
into their apartments and he yes so they
didn't want her and they live in a
12,000 a month apartment so I'm like yo
where are these people getting money
where they got a $112,000 a month
apartment in New York City good day guys
I want you spend a month on food can I
come cook for you at your house who are
you kidding you have an outdoor shower
what's happened there Al any dietary
restrictions I need to know about you
don't murder animals how much do you
guys pay for rent in New York around
12,000 could I have a tour of your
apartment okay this is the master
bedroom this is your bathroom oh there
heated floors big fur though cuz vegans
my favorite pair okay this those ones so
this is the men's bathroom all green for
the fun this room is so cool is this the
guest bathroom so this is where you put
me I like the color waves you guys have
going on it doesn't feel very New York
wo that looks so real it's a frame TV so
dope this is f that's cool this is where
all veg cooking happens it drains from
that like that right and when you stop
it back up
always and like makes it like pinky purp
you guys have great parties to the next
I'm coming I'm coming out on the Terrace
oh this is great
detail You're The Mastermind of this
apartment is that what I'm hearing yeah
there's an upstairs okay you made this
yeah I made it it didn't come out that
great w two outdoor spaces this is
actually insane outdoor shower [__] is
crazy apparently her husband who's like
some kind of Indian dude who makes money
money doing like Buddhist stuff I don't
know listen to be honest with you
whenever I see people who he's he's an
author I think yeah a Buddhist book yeah
$112,000 a month Hey listen I'm just
saying I don't know could be I'm just
saying I see podcasts I see spirituality
I see yapping and I see a lavish
lifestyle and I think scamming is
somewhere involved if it makes a lot of
money just say this is the V but no way
to prove it I didn't want to do a deep
dive it just I understand the sentiment
and $12,000 a month is a lot yeah it is
the reason that men and even like a lot
of women will say their sons will do
this too the reason that they get angry
with you for interrupting even when
you're interjecting is because it feels
so confusing to them so they think if
I'm confused then you must be doing
something rude if you've disrupted my
train of thought then you must be being
rude so they take it out on you but they
don't know that what's going on is they
just can't listen and think and talk at
the same time it's just not how they're
brains were built so they're going to
lash out at you if you do
[Laughter]
that you can't listen and talk and you
can't listen and talking tin at the same
time no I I I could yeah I could say
yeah you can't but nobody can it's
not a way to
have what do we what's going on it's not
a proper way to have a conversation I
can't listen and talk nobody can I can
assure you nobody can listen think and
talk at the same time in her defense I
do know some people who that's how they
always talk and so that's that's how
they have their conversations they're
all interjecting and jumping on which is
okay yes but if you're trying to solve a
point that is not a way to solve a point
that's not to Sol a way to solve a
matter if I'm trying to let's say we
have a misunderstanding or something
like like are you saying right now you
can't think and talk at the same
time what were you saying because I was
just talking and you spoke over me
and you can't do conflict resolution
like that I'll be honest with you I have
never heard somebody who's an effective
Communicator saying thinking and talking
at the same time is a good idea men have
a hard time hearing and talking at the
same time so no matter what you say it's
an interruption you know when you're
talking to a man and you're adding
things on to what he's saying you're
agreeing with him but he's getting mad
at you because for some reason he thinks
you're disagreeing for a woman adding on
to the conversation is building Rapport
interjection is much different than an
interruption even when I explained this
in another video men still kept saying
just stop interrupting you're being rude
men need to realize that if we're adding
on to what you're saying we are agreeing
and yeah but we didn't ask you
to sometimes we just want to be able to
get our thought out to feel like we're
hurt when you're interrupting it or
interjecting or adding on it doesn't
feel like we're being heard properly so
you might be thinking you're doing
something good for us but that's not
what we asked for you know what I'm
saying it's kind of like when you make
me a plate of food all of a sudden you
want to start throwing salt and pepper
and season it for me I say no no I'm
good and you just doing it without
asking it's okay for me to be like can
you stop and you do it often oh no no I
think you need some butter over here I
don't even like
butter it's just like let me do my thing
and afterwards you can do your thing
yeah but they're adding to the food why
won why won't you let her feed you you
know the irony of it is is like they
think they doing better for you and
you're not accepting it so you're in the
wrong it sounds a lot like misogyny
don't it when men try to tell women what
it is they supposed to be doing cuz they
think what's right for them I hate that
what it but a lot of time like a lot
they don't realize that they do that
which is fair which is fair but if
you're being told hey it bothers me then
that's the point where you might be to
think like okay cuz here's the thing
what did she say at the beginning let's
say everything she said is true men
can't think and talk at the same time
let's say I agree with you men are the
inferior
communicators how are you being helpful
by interrupting me while I'm talking
that's all this whole thing about the
inferior Communicator is just so funny
to me it's so it's like there's people
that communicate and people that don't
all right stop saying that men don't
know how to communicate and stuff like
that it's funny how we always want men
we always say that women are better
communicators than men women are better
communicators but then we are the one
that needs to [__] uh uh we need to
guess everything that you say if you're
such a good communicator why don't you
just say it no we have to read body
language read minds read palms reading
the crystals read everything we're the
worst communicators but yet we have to
do a lot of the [__] work to
communicate yet you there the
communication experts do [__] nothing
and then you're just being like yeah no
I'm I know I know what you want you want
this let me [__] talk lady let me
[__] talk
whoa
whoa was that too much you just start
swearing out of nowhere is it necessary
for you to be aggressive I'm adding to
the
conversation it's kind of like when you
make a really good point and at the end
you say [__] and then nothing else
before yeah
but there nothing else did you just say
[__] but but that's oh yeah excuse me oh
yeah was that kind of tone necessary but
what what about the rest of the [__]
that I say no nothing none of that
matters let me build the Rapport by
adding on to what you said days but
that's that's oh my God I agree with you
I just didn't like the to I got some
triggers right now so uh when you're
having a conversation and you're trying
to resolve something don't
interrupt for for agreeing or not
agreeing don't I'll say this so some of
the comments from the ladies it says
it's a lecture not a conversation he
hates when I interrupt but he also
doesn't like it when I'm silent and he
feels like he's lecturing me yeah it's
cuz I don't I don't want you to
interrupt me but I don't want to finish
my what I'm saying and then you're
standing there silent cuz I didn't let
you like of course you sound like you
being can we have an in between Jesus
[__] Christ just a in between bro
this was my biggest issue in my last
relationship I couldn't even say yeah or
mhm while he talked conversations with
men are either lectures or
interrogations it depends with who it
really depends with who I call it
engaging with the
conversation oh listen nobody wants to
be lectured to you don't want to hear
some monologue of five or 6 seven
minutes I also don't want to hear mhm
yeah yeah yeah the whole time I'm
talking cuz it feels like are you even
listening to me or you just giving me
affirmative stuff like I know I think
listening is an active skill I think
reflecting on something person's head
takes seconds if you're constantly just
yapping the whole time I'm talking then
it doesn't feel like I'm really being
hurt if it's such a chore for you to not
be able to say mm yeah the whole time
while I'm talking like how much effort
are you really willing to put into
communication all I'm asking is for like
let me say my peace and then you can say
your peace and then we go back and forth
is that crazy is that like men being
that oppressive is that crazy I don't
know I don't think I never thought this
would be something I've never had this
argument in my relationship personally
I've never had a partner said didn't
feel heard by me but I also never had a
Partners who would interrupt me every
time I try to speak like they were very
cordial and respectful now so this
Behavior I just never personally see I
don't think it has nothing to do with
men and women some men do it some some
women do it men can never find anything
around the house because their Vision
did not evolved to see the entire
picture they're completely tunnel vision
so you can't get mad at your husband
every time he can't find the remote or
the keys or the juice in the fridge
because they literally can't see it
they're basically blind on either side
and can only see this right in front of
them it's the reason
that man can see and find things in the
house because you move
them that's why it's cuz you move them
when you feel that it's not at its place
you put it somewhere else that I didn't
I didn't put there that's it or
[__] add it's not even a a
husband thing there's plenty of wives
out there that can't find some things oh
there's women right now in the comments
typing like I can't find [__] I can't
find [__] like how she said evolutionary
like any of this makes sense like how do
you think men were the hunter gatherers
like how do you think they ever spent
time in the woods trying to catch
animals like you have to have good Prof
Vision I don't know it's just the
confidence with which they bring in they
they have turn they didn't evolve to
biologically have the
Vision but they go out hunting with
their friends and they can find a deer
please please it so crazy how often
people get online and start saying
evolutionarily speaking biologically
speaking and sight [__] that is not real
anywhere in any book women have Superior
sensory equipment and analyze
information more rapidly between the two
hemispheres of their brain which makes
them much better at deciphering
non-verbal cues whereas men don't have
that capability that's why you can't get
mad at your man if he doesn't understand
that you're upset you could be acting
like you're upset all day and he'll be
like what do you mean like you're fine
because they can't the masters of
communication cuz they can read the new
non-verbal cues oh they they could they
can read it a man can't you know what
how about you just say it say what the
[__] is on your mind
Lady it's funny how you want someone in
a man that is open to saying what he
feels and what's on his heart but I
gotta decipher what the hell's on yours
I gotta read cues what amount of FBI you
know why we don't like that and we don't
pick it up cuz it's easier when you use
your mouth
pause but it is easier when you use your
mouth but biologically speaking women
had to be guarded with their emotions
and the word that they said because
their husbands could choose to leave
them at any point so evolutionarily
speaking they chose not to open up and
be direct cuz they needed their men to
understand and make the emotional labor
to come meet them
halfway I gave you a real valid response
I interjected to add report to what you
were already saying talking and thinking
at the same time right now that's why
you're not making sense cuz as a man you
can't so I need you to stop trying I
need you to stop
trying
God my God stop my god listen guys no I
think you made a valid point can you
stop producting I want any report I'm
agreeing with you I don't want the
report I'm agreeing with you [__] man
it's always like that we agree with them
they can't
[__] all right well this is what she
used to do before she did this dating
stuff ready we could be Quantum
entangled with our future selves we know
that quantum entanglement exists Quantum
particles are attached in a way that
they can affect each other come back yo
yo priest you and I are quantumly
attached to this channel we have a
responsibility to get back here no I'm
not the quantum physics are calling you
back let's go
Einstein hey hey let's
go I have no idea what this Quantum
let's keep listening in regard to space
or time at all Consciousness is
connected to this Quantum field if you
put attention on one of these particles
that is how they appear in our reality
in terms of quantum physics and the law
attraction if you are putting attention
on your future self whatever that
version of that future self is you're
potentially literally creating
that hey yo I feel like the pot started
in the back cuz she cooking soup
[__] I can feel the heat that soup is
soupy she just freak a little Quantum a
little physics a little attraction a
little love
I would add a little bit more
crystals just a little bit a little bit
more crystals put that myth in there
let's go hey maybe mying this is crazy
and you know what's so funny I swear
I've noticed this literally every person
who becomes one of these dating gurus if
you look at their past jobs it was like
sales spirituality some other mumbo
jumbo some [__] uh pyramid scheme
type thing like all of them seem to come
for these backgrounds I'm the there is
something so consistent about this you
just notice a certain pattern with a lot
of people that enter this world who
become gurus who like they didn't really
have their [__] before they got into
this realm and then they found a nich
and all of a sudden they're experts in
this no credentials none of that [__] is
just quantum physics that has nothing to
do with the laws of physics it just
borrows the same name cuz we're
attaching ourselves to molecules and and
and and particles that are quantumly
attached to the person we're in love
with thus creating an eternal Bond and
also we are also you know different
charges because neutrons Proton Pro
protons and stuff like that so we have
the positive negative charge you know
what I mean Laws of Attraction and stuff
and sometimes the polar of some people
whichwich you know what I mean when you
attract them you were maybe a negative
and they were positive so it went
together but when both of you they went
in a negative phase in your relationship
and you switch somehow some way the
polers of that person and became a
negative and you're too negative and
that's how your relationship ends
because negative
negative physics your aura is glowing
right now
oh
oh e you a is glowing get the yeah
shining brighter than my
future AB your aura
is I feel like I could really see oh
like the other your past cells like that
other chick watching that old gezer oh
my God you're so like your AA it's just
so you just feel like an old
witch yo run that [__]
back run
that yo preach the old witch I'm the old
witch
yeah it's just your presence it is crazy
your presence is so present even her her
husband like everything about these
people just give scammer Vibes I I don't
know what it is it just it it it does it
really does just one more spirituality
thing before this whole philosophy of
why people get bored we might have
experienced this before in a past life
and we now see this thing as boring and
the only way to break out of that and
not be consistently bored with your life
and to have every meal feel new and to
have every person feel new is to just be
present to the moment the past doesn't
exist hey man I enjoy this kind of stuff
but
hey I shouldn't poo poo this kind of
spiritual stuff maybe it's a layer of
understanding that I just haven't
achieved yet a man has to be on his girl
side especially if it's in public and
even more so if it's about another girl
even if you don't logically think that
she's correct it doesn't matter you're
not a referee your job is not to be
impartial your job is to be her man if
you do disagree with her you better make
sure it doesn't sound like you're siding
with another female what are you trying
to do make another woman feel more
special trust me you are not doing that
girl any favors all she's going to see
is a guy who disrespects his woman
thoughts not a lot of thoughts
there well what if that's you in that
situation no if you're wrong you're
wrong it's like I will tell you you are
wrong it's okay like when we go
somewhere when we go somewhere it's
not it's not it's it's not like in the
setting where like there's a lot of
people and then we interact it's not
like our power couple versus the world
and this and that no we meet people and
we have different uh opinion about
different stuff right and I can to have
different opinions uh around stuff and
she can have different opinions and we
can have different opinions that's
that's because uh that's because we are
our own different individual human being
uh I don't become her she doesn't become
me it's just we're still a human being
and is the wonderful you have to
practice the wonderful art of agreeing
to disagree when you disagree with
someone it doesn't mean that you are an
enemy you're just not on the same point
I think you're trying to make the other
girl feel special yes but is you're not
you're it's so ass it's so kindergarten
[__] that's now you got to have her back
cuz y'all a team and y'all against the
other team that's that's high school
[__]
you know but if we go somewhere and then
or even if I'm wrong I want someone to
check me if I'm
wrong I just couldn't have and then and
then we're we're like we meet you we
talk about something you say something I
say something back and I make no sense
yeah I want the person to be able to
tell me you're like yo fresh and fit are
super talented and I'm like no they're
not and I L all the reasons why they not
and your girl agrees with me like she
doing the right thing by letting you
know yeah exactly of course yeah she got
to let me know exactly cuz you walk
around just wearing a fresh and fit
hoodie going
that no we can't have that no we can't
have that her by by her me US teaming up
we saving you from being wrong sure but
you're not trying to make her feel
special yeah and she agree with me I
won't be like okay
baby even your wife my [__] even your
wife is on my side yeah you're wrong
he's wrong H it's my wife now like like
you making it sound like she agree with
me all of a sudden she reaching for my
balls or something like yo relax it's
just it's not it's not it's not the it's
it's not what's going on
like what's going
on what is happening with people
people's ego that that [__] you up so
much yeah man I really didn't appreciate
you agreeing with you what what happens
in your ego that you're so uncertain
about yourself that oh what what 1 + 1
equals 2 now
you're just trying to make her feel
special what's wrong with with with
people also it's okay to be wrong like
forget the she said a comment she say
you're not a referee your job is not to
be impartial no but it is to help my
partner make sure like they on the right
track of things and also to give my
honest feedback now of course you know
I'm not going to be out here just
[__] on my hey you dumb [__] you
got the wrong answer that's not what
you're doing no but it's like no I think
actually what she says makes more sense
if you if your ego can't handle the fact
that you may be incorrect about
something in public then you're whole I
might have just married the wrong person
you're you're a whole toddler yeah
you're a toddler I think there's a way
to do it without diminishing your
partner and making them look like an
idiot like it's okay to be wrong about
stuff yeah I don't have to [__] run
through the [__] be like you
dumb ass mother I I that's why I drive
and you don't you know like you don't
have to go to that extent but Jesus
Christ if you can't even handle that
you're a whole ass toddler and you need
to work on yourself but this is like
very US versus them mentality but let's
keep watching
yeah you made her feel oh you my girl we
going you made her you made her feels
better why did you why did
you why did you make your feel let's
watching no B I think you got to take
people for people and I think you have
to figure out how they like to
communicate and work with them on that
basis they I've had Partners who were
very outspoken and wanted to Tex off and
I had other partners who didn't I had
Partners who wanted to have heated back
and forth we could yell and out of
Partners who would shut down if I try to
interject in the way that they didn't
like and it was my job as my as a
partner to meet them halfway to try to
make sure that they felt comfortable
enough to communicate okay so you have
to understand there's label that you
have to do and if it just means not
having to do certain things while you're
partner talking it should be okay all
this talk about women this is how you
have a partner help them out all this
man versus woman nonsense all this [__]
like I've just met too many women who
operate differently in a lot of
different Realms to think that I could
have a one size fits all thing and I
would hope that for women it's been the
same in regards to how they work with
their men if not if you dating the same
[__] with the same problems all
the time you probably picking a certain
type I'm just saying cuz I can assure
you the way even me and my roommate
communicate is different have a whole
ass Mr Mr robotto [__] going on at women
must act this way it's like very binary
it's this or that this or that let us
know what you guys think in the comments
below we want to hear from you